hello everyone here on the free codecamp
channel wanting to learn how to make
your own crm with google sheets or
postgres sql i say or as i will be
showing you how to build the crm with
both so if you are more comfortable with
google sheets we will start off with
that or if you want to use a database i
will be showing you how to make it in
postgres sql 2. my name is annie cooper
and i'm a software developer and course
creator on youtube i am also your host
for this actionpap video for all skill
levels it is my personal mission to show
you that anyone can make a crm or
customer relationship management system
and make it customizable to them and
their business
a crm is essentially a way to manage
your customer data for example imagine
having thousands and thousands of
customers it would become virtually
impossible to remember which one of your
customers bought what when or when the
last time that you emailed them was
crms allow you to add this data to the
system filter through it to find
customers based on a variety of
variables and even automate your
processes such as sending thank you
emails or payment reminders the main
purpose of crms has traditionally been
improving customer service and driving
sales
crm softwares actually have been around
since the late 1990s but have really
flourished in the recent years
some examples of famous crms are
salesforce oracle netsuite for larger
enterprises and hubspot and freshwork
for smaller businesses
now there are many reasons why you might
want to build your own crm for me the
most obvious is that crms can be
expensive and often you are paying for
features that you don't really care
about that much
using low code solutions such as the one
we will be using in this course allows
you to create your own personalized crm
experience totally for free or at least
at a fraction of the traditional price
this crm will allow you to store your
data in a visual way meaning we will be
creating dynamic graphs and charts as
well as allows you to add or edit data
from the platform itself it will also
allow you to perform refunds directly
from the platform using the strike api
as well as send out automated emails
based on templates of your choice
api stands for application programming
interface they allow for technologies to
essentially talk with each other and are
essential to so many services that we
rely on today they are in fact behind
most apps we use on a day-to-day basis
and they can shape the information pass
between one technology to another apis
are everywhere we are in fact going to
be using the stripe api and a mailing
api in this course but there are so many
you can choose from to improve your crm
offering
this course is going to adopt what is
considered a low code approach to
creating platforms this means there are
no hard coding prerequisites for doing
this course although unlike no code and
understanding in the fundamentals of
html css and javascript are advised if
you want to take your project to the
next level in terms of styling and
functionality
to break it down for you here is what we
are going to learn step by step
in part one we will build out our crm
from google sheets in which we will
fetch all of our data into the platform
but then also learn how to add new data
to the existing google sheet directly
from the platform we have built we will
also learn how to edit data 2 so that it
is saved back in the google sheet
afterwards
next in part 2 we will integrate stripe
for processing refunds thanks to the
pre-configured stripe api after that in
part 3 we will learn how to send out
automated email notifications with the
mailing api
and finally in part 4 we will upgrade
and transition the backend away from
google sheets and to postgres sql for
scalability and to handle more complex
features
ok
so what are we waiting for let's go to
building out our crm
okay so welcome to the retool platform
this is the platform that we will be
using for this tutorial in order to
create a dashboard that looks like this
okay so in order to
do this i'm gonna start off by creating
a new project on the main dashboard here
are some previous projects that i have
done we're gonna go ahead and just click
here to create a blank app and let's go
ahead and give this a name so i'm going
to call this fcc
crm and just click create app which will
take me to this blank dashboard okay so
here we go here is our blank dashboard
with a table that has been created for
us just as a demonstration i'm going to
simply go ahead and delete that table to
truly make this a blank slate
now
we are going to be working with some
data now in any sort of situation say
you're a small business owner and you
have a lot of data that you then want to
use to create an app that's the angle
that we're going to go with okay so we
are going to take this sample data from
northwind
right here
this sample data will provide us with a
table of categories
regions for our customers territories
customer demographics customer
demographics again a table of employees
to show which employee deals with which
customer and order employee by territory
supplier
product
shipper the sales order itself the order
details and so on and then we're going
to insert all that data so this is the
data that we are going to work with for
the first part of this tutorial i have
gone ahead and put all of this data in a
google spreadsheet for you as you will
see here here all our customer there is
a lot of data we also have the
sales orders and so on and so on
if you would like to make your own table
all you have to do is go to your google
drive or sign up if you don't have an
account create a spreadsheet here by
clicking on google sheets and start
creating columns and rows
you can even label the tabs down here as
previously seen and create new tabs with
new tables so that is just some
background for you on google sheets and
how to create your own but for now and
for this tutorial if you want to follow
along please go ahead and just use the
table with the northwind data i pre-made
this data mimics a generic company that
receives orders
these orders are represented by rows
here in this table which we have put in
a tab called sales orders
data in the sales order table can also
link to specific products that can be
cross-linked to here
employees that deal with the orders the
customers that make the order and so on
and so on can also be linked
i would advise taking a moment here to
really understand what is going on in
this database
so i will be sharing this link with you
in the description below please go ahead
and have a look at that once again here
are all our orders there are up to
831 orders that we are going to be
working with so
great a lot of data let's carry on
so the first thing i'm going to do is
create a new
resource
so let's go ahead and go to our resource
page here you can see all the resources
available to us
i'm going to go ahead and select the
google sheet one on this occasion as we
want to be able to connect the google
sheet we are looking at to the platform
so these are the steps you will need to
do in order to make that happen
great
so now let's go back to our app and
don't forget to refresh the page
now i'm going to make a new query and as
the resource i'm going to choose the new
resource we just made which is called
northwind crm data so there we go we
have officially linked up our google
sheet to this platform so now let's go
back to the app we are building we are
just going to use a component the table
component to be precise from the ui
panel on the right in order to map all
our data onto it okay so that is what we
are going to do if it helps i like to
think of this platform as having a
bottom panel that is to make queries a
panel on the right that is for all our
ui components and a panel on the left
which is for seeing the shape of our
data that comes back to us after we make
a query
i will be showing you this later on
okay so now we can actually pick a
spreadsheet id
and i'm just going to select northwind
data as that is what we called our
google sheet here and for the sheet name
well the first thing that i want to get
is all the sales orders so let's go
ahead and select that
here sales orders just typing that in
making sure that it's spelt exactly the
same way
that we did right here sales order sales
order
great
and just click save and run
so now we should see all our data coming
up down here
wonderful i'm just going to rename this
to get
sales
or
the
data so that it's more readable for us
later on
wonderful so we are now getting all our
sales order data and to create a table
with it well what i'm going to do is
just drag a table in here and there we
go we will see our table populate with
all the sales order data this is because
we are on this query our query here is
selected so it knows to use this query
in order to populate our table
while we're here i'm just going to get
rid of this query as we are not using it
at the moment
wonderful
so there is our table it is looking good
let's carry on
before we move on i'm actually just
going to edit this table a little bit so
that it looks a little bit neater for us
so let's do that now so i can simply
click on the columns here and rename the
column if i want so for example maybe
let's call this order id like so
and that will update in here let's also
get the customer id so i'm just going to
go
just like so and so on
so while we are here i'm also going to
show you that you can format each of the
columns so for example the required date
well if i click on this
i can even choose date time local time
zone or original time zone it is
completely up to you whichever one you'd
wish let's go with original time zone
like so and that will format the date to
be a little bit more readable for us as
opposed to this format right here
let's do the same on the
shipped date
so once again let's go ship date and
just select
column type
original time zone and you will see that
changing and finally on the order date
i'm just going to click here
column type
date time original time zone
wonderful
so this is already looking a bit better
while i am here let's have a look at
what else we can do we can of course
also hide columns so for example perhaps
i don't want the ship region all i would
do is simply go here and click on the
little i to hide it and i'm also going
to hide the shipper id
and the freight
number
okay so that is looking better with the
information that i want
one thing to note here is that i
actually added this charge id this
charge id is from stripe i have added it
in the sales order right here so this
column has been added by me and i have
done this so that we can demonstrate how
to issue straight refunds on particular
orders so once again this was not with
the northwind data here this is a column
that i populated myself and created
myself but don't worry if you're using
the link in the description below you
should see this too
okay so while we're here i'm just going
to rename all of these as well so let's
maybe change this to amp id for employee
id
let's also do
order
date
shipped
date
required
date
ship name i'm actually going to hide i
don't really think we need this ship
address i'm just going to put
ship address like so
ship city i'm just going to give us city
postcode i'm going to put postal
code let's just leave this as
country
and the
charge
id
wonderful so this is already looking
much
better
for
me
great
so we have our table
this is looking good let's go ahead and
add a few more tables while we're here
so i can go ahead and perhaps let's add
the table of customers as i think that
is some good data that i would want as a
startup so once again i would just go
into here click new resource query
making sure that i am on the northwind
crm data as that is the google sheet
that we have linked here i'm going to
read data from a spreadsheet i am also
going to
select which id so northwind data is
what we call this spreadsheet and then
the sheet name well we know that is
customer so i'm simply just going to
type
customer
here and click save and run and while
i'm here i'm going to rename this query
so that we can keep track of them better
get
customer data
just
like
set
great
so now we can put another table in
however i'm going to show you a really
cool way to organize your data we can
use the tabs component
so if i just go ahead and
work in the tabs here i can now put one
table on tab one and another table on
tab too so i'm going to put all my
sales order
i'm just going to drag that
table drag this table up in here
and there we go so these are now our
sales orders we can even put some text
here in order to make this more obvious
to everyone so i'm just going to grab
some text and i'm simply going to put
sales
orders
like so we can also make this
bold
if
we wish
we are using markdown to make this bold
markdown is a lightweight markup
language for creating formatted text
using a plain text editor it's the same
thing you use when writing github
readmes you can find all the syntax you
need here if you wish
so there we go now it's more clear that
sales orders and then i can also do so
on tab two so on tab two this is going
to be
customers
so i'm just going to put customers
making sure that it's spelled correctly
like so and making sure i'm on the query
i'm just going to grab a table
and just put it here in order to
populate this with the data that we see
from our query displaying right here
after we have run the query
so there we go
great
once again if you wish you can choose to
hide certain things perhaps let's go
ahead and hide a few now because this is
quite a lot information so perhaps i
don't want the fax number i can go ahead
and hide that
i can also hide the region if i wish
it is totally up
to me so perhaps i will either regen i
think this is enough data for me and of
course we can just
pull that out
like
so
great
so we've got our customer data
and then we also have our sales orders
we can also of course rename the tab so
i can do so right here
sales
orders
and then we have
customers
as well
so
there we go
i'm gonna actually do one more table
before we continue adding other things
another table that i would like to add
is the table of orders themselves
because at the moment we can see here
the order number and it gives us the
information about the customer and the
shipping date and the status however i
just want to know what is exactly
associated with this order so for this
i'm actually going to use the
order detail
so i'm going to get this table in here
so once again new resource query
making sure that i am on northwind crm
data i'm going to read data
and i'm going to choose the sheet
northwind data and the sheet name is
order detail so i'm just going to go
order
detail
like so making sure that it's for
correct and save and run
and there we go
so we have that here let's also rename
this to get
order
details
i'm just going to drag that once again
up here so that we can see the order
details
just
like
that
okay
wonderful
so this is looking good once again
perhaps let's put some text here just to
let everyone know that these are
order
details
and i'm going to get rid of that emoji
we can actually do some editing on here
too so for example here is my tab we can
style the tab with all these
pre-configured things or we can you know
google fully custom at the moment i'm
simply just going to choose
to change the
header like so
so i'm going to choose to make this
white
and that's already looking a little bit
more stylish for me please feel free to
go wild that part is totally up to you
so there we go we have now completed the
part where we put in all our tables now
i'm going to show you how to create pie
charts and visually show this data
thanks to these components right here so
i'm just going to go and use a component
such as chart in order to do this or we
can make a progress circle that part is
completely up to us for now though i'm
just going to create a new tabs
item here so tabs component i'm just
going to drag that in so that we can
display different types of data on
different tabs so i'm just going to make
this a little bit bigger like so
and
great
and once again i'm just going to change
the header background to be white so i
can simply just drag this up here or i
can put in f f f fff to symbolize white
by myself
so tab one i think the tab one is going
to be an overview so let's make this an
overview and it's going to just be an
overview of the amount of orders that we
have shipped so i'm going to use the
table right here i'm going to use the
ship date in order to show us how many
orders have been shipped and i'm also
going to use the table data here in
order to show us how many items have
been sold at full price okay because you
can see discounts have implied to some i
want to know exactly how many orders we
have sold at full price
so to do this i'm simply going to get
the progress circle and drag it in here
just
like
so
so here we have a progress circle and
now let's link it up
at the moment the value is hard coded
however we don't have to hard code it we
can
use the
table data in order to make this dynamic
so as we said we want to show how many
orders have been fulfilled or in other
words shipped so we are going to get our
sales order data which is an array and
we are going to use the javascript
method of filter to filter out each
order that has a ship date of not an
empty string as if it is not an empty
string it means a ship date exists and
we can say this order is fulfilled
next we are going to find out how many
of those exist and we will do so with
the length property on the array we will
then get that value and divide it by the
total amount of orders in the get sales
order data array and multiply it by 100
as that is how percentages work
okay so fulfilled orders over total of
orders multiplied by 100 will give us
the percentage of fulfilled orders
so to do this this is the syntax for
doing so in here i need to get these two
curly braces well we know that this
table is made up of get sales ordered
data so let's get says order data get
sales order
data and we need to get it data so we
can use this in order to see how the
data is formed so here is get sales
order data and you will see that comes
back as an object that object has data
in it which is why we are getting data
and data is an array it's an array of
different objects so
let's filter our array i'm going to use
the javascript method of filter to
filter out each item in the array let's
call it an order so like so
order and for each order in our array
i'm going to get the orders
shipped
date
and if it does not equal
an empty string
then i want to get this array's length
and then just divide it over the get
sales
order
data
data length so the length of the entire
array
ah there was a spelling mistake here
let's go ahead and correct get sales
order data
there we go get sales order data
and now let's multiply by this 100
because that is how you would get a
percentage so there we go
a percentage so just talking this
through again what we are doing is
getting the sales order data that we see
here
so as you can see here this is the
object that returns back we're then
going into data which is an array
essentially of all this information and
for each item in this array which we
have called order we're going to filter
out by the
shipped
date so this right here and if ship date
is null so it doesn't contain anything
well then we know that it's not been
shipped and then we're going to divide
that by the length of this entire array
so by the amount of items in these sales
orders and multiply by 100 because that
is how you'd get the percentage so as
you will see here 97 of our orders have
been shipped so in other words 97 of our
orders have a
shipped
date
wonderful
so hopefully that was easy
let's carry on
so now once again i'm just going to drag
over some text
let's drag that over here
and let's do shift orders
just so people could know what we are
talking about shift
or
just
let's again just get rid of the emoji we
don't need that
and then we can also have some text to
tell us exactly the percentage so once
again i'm just going to drag that up
here
and we can do something like this so i'm
just going to get rid of that
currently
and then we can put the percentage in
there if we want currently
97
of all
orders
have
been
shipped just so it's super clear to
whoever's reading and once again this
should be easy we can actually grab the
value of this if we want so this is
progress circle one so i can
instead of doing the calculation again
just get progress circle one
and i can
get its
value
so there we go and we can use some
javascript on this to make it to two
decimal places if we wish to fix and
then just pass through a two
just like
so
great so this is looking good let's just
add a percentage here and
wonderful
so now that we've done that how do you
think we would make a percentage for all
the orders that have been sold at full
price
well
once again i would simply grab a
progress circle so this is progress
circle number two this time
i'm just going to put that in here
and this time let's get the
get order details so get order details
data that's correct so i don't want the
value 6 to be card coded i want to get
the order details data
get order details
data which is the array and this time
i'm actually going to filter by the
discount
so
very similarly to what we did last time
we can use the filter javascript method
to filter each order so i'm just going
to put order i'm going to call every
item in the array an order and for each
order i'm going to get the order
discount
discount because that is what it's
called here the order
it's going to an item
discount and if the order discount
equals the string of 0
because that is what we have here we
have strings of zero not numbers
then i want to get the length of the
array so i want to get exactly how many
have the string of zero under discount
and divide this by the
array itself so get order details data
dot length and of course multiply it
by a hundred to get a
percentage so there we go making sure
that this is in two curly braces because
that is the syntax for doing so
okay great so we can see 61
of my orders have been sold at full
price so i'm just going to copy that
and then once again let's just get the
progress circle 2 value this time
currently 61.11
of all orders
have
been
sold
at
full price and then let's just make sure
we have no spelling mistakes here either
and
great
and once again let's perhaps just give
this a
title
this time saying
full price orders so full
price
orders
just
like
so i'm just making sure that they are
all
aligned
correctly to make them look
good next to each other so
there we go
okay great so we have now learned how to
use the
progress circles the next thing i'm
going to show you is how to show a
statistic so let's go ahead and perhaps
this time show something like the total
of all the orders so for this i'm just
going to get the unit price and add it
all up okay so that's what i want to do
and multiply it by the quantity sold so
unit price by quantity and for this i'm
actually going to use a statistics
component so we already have this here
it's already sort of nicely styled for
us to look like a statistic so there we
go let's also perhaps move these down
now i'm just going to move these down
of course the styling is completely up
to you please feel free to go wild on
the styling however you wish i'm also
going to put in a divider
so just whack that in here again this is
just a styling preference please feel
free to style this up however you wish
once you have got two grips with the
retool tool
okay
so just putting these circles back like
that
that's making them smaller
again you could just fiddle around as
this forever
so please just bear with me
and great so here i want to show the
total of all the oldest salts i'm just
going to put total
in
like so total
and then here well we don't want to hard
code this once again let's get up our
curly braces because we want to get we
can also do it by table so this is table
three let's get table three let's get
the data in it
and we just want to go by selected row
so i can use selected row selected
row
and then i can get the data and what i
can do is get its quantity
and then i just have to multiply it by
the
table 3
selected
row
data
unit
price
okay so now whatever row i click on
it will show me the
total
so that is looking pretty good perhaps
let's maybe make this clear what this is
total
of selected
row and now we can simply get the total
just by clicking the row so that is
quite handy for us as small business
owners i also just want to perhaps get
rid of this as it doesn't really mean
anything so let's get rid of the caption
here and i don't really need this
increase amount
so we don't want a positive trend
i'm just gonna delete that like so
great
so there we go now we've just made a
useful tool to essentially show us the
total of the selected row the next thing
i want to do is just show us the total
amount of customers that we have in this
dashboard and the total amount of orders
okay so this is really an overview this
tab is everything to do with an overview
of the total dashboard so let's go ahead
and do that
so this time i'm simply just going to
use text to do this and in here i want
to be able to show all the customers
that we have so i'm just going to once
again perhaps i'm just going to hard
code customers here like
so and then in here well i do want to
display the amount of customers that we
have so to do this i'm going to use get
customer data
and then just get the length of all of
this data right here because this data
is the customer data so if i just simply
go by length of the amount of
essentially rows that we have that
should give me the customer amount that
we
have in this dashboard so there we go
once again if we look at this table all
i've done is simply get the length of
the array and the array symbolizes the
rows
okay so each array item is essentially a
row so if i just count the rows it will
show me the amount of customers that we
have
great
so there's our customer data
i can of course spread this out a little
bit if i wish
and here we can have the order data so
this is going to be the amount orders
and once again to get the order amount
well i'm simply going to get the sales
order data so get
sales
order data
data and then just get the length
great
so now we can see the amount of orders
that we have we can also see the amount
of customers and if i add orders to this
table this should change dynamically
so this is looking good there is our
overview let's
carry
on
let's have a look at tab 2.
for tab 2 i want to show exactly what
the work distribution is by employee
so if we have a look at these sales
orders you will see that each order we
can actually have a look here as well
has an employer id by it
so right here employer id so we know
what order is assigned to which employee
but we want to see that visually so for
this i am just going to use another
component this time i want to create a
pie chart so to do this i'm going to go
to charts and i'm just going to drag
this over like
so
and i'm also going to select pie chart
and this time we are getting the sales
order data that is correct however i
just want to show the data by its
employer id so under value labels let's
select employer id just like so
and there we go
so now we can see all the work done by
employer id
so essentially what is happening here is
that we can see that employer number
four
has the most work as the most orders
assigned to them
so this is looking good
let's carry on the next thing i want to
do is actually show me the employer's
name by this number right because we
have the data here if you look here we
have the employees along with the
employer id
so once again i'm going to go in here
and click a new resource query making
sure that northwind crm data is selected
but this time making sure that northwind
data is selected too as the spreadsheet
name i want to get the employee
making sure that it's spelled exactly
the same as it's spelt here so emplo
and just click save and run
and once again i'm just going to get a
table making sure that on this query
let's call this get
employee
data
and i'm just going to drag in a table
right here
and that will show me all the employee
data
just
like
so
so this is looking good i can now get
the employee
data i can also hide things of course
like for example let's say i just want
their name
i can do so very easily
like
this by hiding all the other
tabs
great so now we have the employee id we
have their last name their first name as
well as their title wonderful and let's
just rename this tab to distribution
so work distribution distribution
like so and i'm just going to make
another tab and this time the tab that i
want to create is a tab called team
and a title another one called demo
graphic to show us where most of our
orders come from
great now for team well i'm actually
just going to get the same table right
here and i'm just going to show us all
the data that we sort of had before
because i think it's useful to have you
know all the employee data not just the
first name and the last name so that we
can filter through it so this is going
to hold all our team data
just like so and demographic well as we
said the demographic i want us to show
exactly where most of our orders are
coming from so i can do so easily
once again i'm going to use a pie chart
for this so let's go ahead and find a
pie chart
and this time i actually want to get the
customer data let's get the customer
data let's do it by where the customer
is based customer data
just like so making sure this is a pie
chart
and this time i just want to get the
country because that's what i want to
display i want to show what the
breakdown is by country for all our
customers
so just like that we can even position
this uh however we want so perhaps this
is a good way and wonderful you will see
that most of our customers come from the
us just by simply dragging a pie chart
like so
okay great
so this is looking good
let's
move on i'm just going to drag this a
bit lower
to make sure that's on the same level we
will be doing all the styling a bit
later on this is looking good for now
so great we are displaying all the data
that we have in the google spreadsheet
we are picking out which sheets we want
to use and then we are also getting an
overview of the data that we have
imported in here in various tabs that we
have made
the next thing that i want to do is
actually add data from our spreadsheet
so i'm going to show you how to do this
now
so as we mentioned at the moment we're
just reading data i can also add data to
this spreadsheet from this platform
to do this i'm going to show you how to
do this first off let's actually create
a modal so i'm going to grab the modal
like so i'm just going to drag it in
here under the sales orders title
and i want this model to pop up and
essentially be able to create a new
order that i add in here so let's go
ahead and do that
a modal is a pop-up window that we are
going to see to add the data to our
spreadsheet as we just mentioned
we will do this by populating the model
with form field inputs and a submit
button so first off what do we want in
our module well we're going to have lots
of inputs essentially input all of this
data but first off let's just start
perhaps with the title i want my title
to say create an order as that is what
is happening here so create
an
order
just like so we can also change the
background so if i perhaps want it
red
so like a red like this that is also
possible
too
okay so there we go and there is an
option to create a form to make our
lives easier so let's go ahead and find
that form first so i'm just going to
search for form
and drag that in
here so now this is good as it comes
with all the button and the styling and
it just makes it a little bit nicer for
us to look at so here's our order form
just dragging this all the way up here
and let's just drag out the title as
well
great and now let's go ahead and get
inputs for all of this data so all of
the data you see in the row we're going
to have to collect so the first thing
that we're going to collect is the order
id
so let's go ahead and do that here
perhaps
the
value we're going to leave empty enter
value or we could have an order number
as the placeholder it is totally up to
us
the label we're going to put order id as
that's what we want to put in here
just like so
and we can hide the label we can show
the label we could also make the label
appear at the top or bottom it is
completely up to you
so there's my input for the label let's
carry on the next input that i need is
to get the employer id
so let's go ahead and do that because
the order date we're going to have to
select so i'm just going to
make that up here so here's a label and
then for this let's call this employee
id
just like so
and once again let's also make the same
for the customer id
so let's put customer id
so customer id employee id the next
thing we do is some dates so let's go
ahead and get a date picker up
so i can do so
quite simply just move these down a
little bit perhaps
and this time let's get the date picker
and just drag that in here
so here we have the date picker
i'm going to call this
ordered by
or ordered date
and then we can select a date
just copy paste that
okay so we've got the order date the
next thing we need is the required by
so required by date
and then finally we need the address
fields so perhaps let's put a divider in
there so i'm just going to drag a
divider in just so we can separate the
two
visually
and now let's get an input so a text
input
just drag it all the way over here and
this is going to be for the address
let's put that below the
divider so it's going to drag the
divider up here
we're also going to have one for the
city
the country
and the region
so here we have four inputs all text
inputs
if whatever reason you need a number
input there is one specifically four
numbers so just bear that in mind
so these are all
text inputs
so we've got the address the next one i
want to be city
this one i want to be country so let's
just change the label of that
and this one i want to be
region
and we have one more thing so we're not
actually done in this address section
because we also need the postcode so
let's also have the
post
code
okay
so that is it for the
region or address parts once again we
let's split this out because we do need
some more things even though we can't
see the ship id and the ship id and the
freight id and they're shipped on date
because we hid some of them we are going
to have to put this into our form as
this data is required i'm simply just
going by the fields here
okay so i'm just going through all of
them and just making sure we are
collecting data for all of those to be
populated
so once again let's just get the divider
out
just drag that across here
and then let's go ahead and just put in
some more inputs so
once again i'm just going to drag that
below here this time let's perhaps make
the label at the top because we're going
to have
three here so one
oops
two three
and then just position them a little bit
so label
one two
and three
and let's have this as ship
name
let's have this as
shipper id
and let's have this as the fright
field freight
shipper id not shipped
and finally we're just going to have a
date picker to pick the date that this
was shipped on so once again let's get
the date picker and just drag that in
here
so just like so and give this the label
of
shipped
on
great so this is looking good and of
course we have the submit button as well
so
nice i'm really happy with how this is
looking so far
okay great so we're collecting all that
data but now we need to essentially get
all this data and get this data to make
a query with it to add data to the
sales order table so what i'm going to
do is create a new query this time this
query let's call this add
sales
order
okay so that's what our query is called
this will be to northwood crm and then
we're going to append data to a
spreadsheet choose the spreadsheet well
that's northwind data and the sheet we
want to add to is sales order so let's
just go ahead and put sales
order like so
and in here what do we need to do well
we need to add
data that looks like
this so let's look in here
let's look at the data
okay and we need to make an object that
essentially looks exactly like this i'm
going to copy that
and i'm going to make an array
so open up the square braces and then we
could just make an object and paste all
the data like so but i think this is
quite messy so i'm going to take you
through this step by step okay so open
up the array make an object and we're
going to copy this object right here so
the first thing that we need to put in
is the
we could start with a charge id let's go
ahead and do that let's just make sure
that everything's in order
so the first one is
charge id always making sure to spell
everything exactly the same as you see
it
so charge id and for now i'm just going
to put the string of test
put a comma and the next thing is the
cust id
so once again let's put the string of
cost id and put the string of test
the next is
id for employee id
and once again i'm putting test
and you get it so fright is next
test
by a comma it's going to copy this
actually because there's a lot of
repetition
fright
order
date
then we have the required date
just paste
next we have the
ship
address
and paste
next we have the
ship
city
and paste
ship country is next so ship
country
ship name
then we have the shipped
date
and the ship
region
okay so that is it let's quickly make
sure that we didn't make any spelling
mistakes even though we will get an
error so
that's all the data that we have
okay and let's check it out so i'm just
gonna click save
and run this
so i'm just gonna get this up a little
bit so we can see what returns back to
us
okay so that runs successfully we saw
the little pop-up now let's have a look
here and go all the way to the bottom of
sales orders as we did append the row to
this table so it should appear at the
very end of this table
and there we go i did press it twice so
two rows have been offended and
everything is working great
wonderful so now that the test is
working let's replace these test strings
with actual values from our form field
right here
so all i'm going to do is match the
input value
to
the
key
okay so there we go charge id well we
know that the charge id at the moment
i'm going to hard code it because all
the charge ids are the same this is just
a test
charge id that i'm getting from the
stripe api that we will go into later so
this one i can hard code so let's go
ahead and do that and put that as a
string
the next thing is the custom id so we
know that that's going to be text input
choose value so i'm just going to
replace this let's get our curly braces
up and i'm going to grab this element
which we called test input 2
test
in put two and i'm going to get its
value
just like
so
that should say text input value
apologies text input value
okay great
so this is looking good we can of course
if we really want to change these so if
i really wanted to rename them i could
so just know that there is an option to
do that i'm not going to do this for
this tutorial as that will take a lot of
time but to know that if i wanted to
change this i could
great
now let's get the employer id so for
this we're going to use text input 3.
get the two curly braces and go text
input
3
dot
value
great
let's do the same for the freight
so here we go that's text input
9. once again
let's just get rid of these
quote marks let's get the test
word here get our curly braces and this
time we need to get text input nine so
text
input
9 dot value
making sure to spell text input
correctly
just like so
the order date well the order date is
date
time two
so let's go ahead and replace the test
value here with
date
time two dot value
the required date once again that is
date time one so i'm just going to get
the test
and use the curly braces to get
date
time 1
what value so it really is this simple
that's all i'm doing
the shipping address or the ship address
in other words
that's going to be text input 7.
so i'm just gonna look at the curly
braces and get text input
seven we can use the drop down to make
our lives a little bit easier the
shipped city
is going to be
six
country is five
and region is
eight so let's try remember that
just gonna
copy this one
ship city we said was
six
ship country
i think we said that was five but we'll
double check
and the ship
region is h
do we have ship region here
uh here we go ship region
so let's make that
eight and just a few more left
we need the postcode which is four
so let's find the postcode in here
there we go
and replace it with text input
and then we just have the ship name
which is 10 ship id 11
and i think that should be it so ship
name
is text input
10
ship id
is
11
and i think there's just two dates left
so let's have a look again back here
uh one date left date one is the shipped
on date so let's just go in here
and this is
date
one
date one
dot
value
so this is looking good let's test it
out so
i'm just going to save that
and this time to test it out
i'm just going to input some data
so let's go ahead and do this
employee id i'm going to say 2 customer
id 3 order id again this is just for
tests let's pick a date so i'm just
going to pick
the date and the time for this one
the address again i'm just going to put
test for now city test
country test
region test
postcode 363
ship name a a
and then fright
a
and then shipped on let's just have a
date for this one
let's go with the tenth of love
and then click run
so now okay
we did get an error why is this so we
can actually read
right here what has happened
and you will see the line has not been
added there was an error and i think it
is something to do with this
uh we have left a little apostrophe
there so that's gone and i think we also
don't have the order id so that is one
we didn't pick out if i'm not mistaken
so i'm just going to put that
in the
front or after the order date
so just in here
just to make sure it's the same as here
for readability so order id
and the order id is going to be the
text input one so text
input one
dot
value
and once again just make sure to
format that correctly so put a comma
there and great so now if we save this
and run it
and have a look in here
well there you go
the row has been updated with the
correct values in each
column
great
so that is now working we have now
figured out a way to add data from this
platform to our google sheet i just need
to do one last thing is that is connect
the button right here so that it
sends when we click this button so i'm
just gonna click that right here so i've
just selected the button if you can see
that
so here we have it and we need on submit
we could make the button full width if
we wish
on submit so there's the submit button
we also want some events and i just want
to trigger the query
add sales order so i want to run this
query rather than us running it manually
i could do it by attaching it to this
button okay so that's what i want to
happen
just like so and we could also add other
things so for example i can also add
instead of trigger a query just to send
confetti so that we know that is done
and then as a third thing so after we
get the sales order data i want to
display it in here so in the table which
means i essentially need to make a
request to get all of this data again so
i need to run the query to get sales
ordered data so i'm just going to do
that in here so in the query rather than
the button and i'm going to trigger the
query get sales order data and save that
so now
when we fill out this form and click the
submit button i'm just going to zoom out
a little bit so you can see the submit
button and when we click the submit
button so let's do another one this time
this time i'm going to put order id
www at the end and i'm just going to
click submit so
we are making a query to add data to
this google sheet we are then sending
the confetti and we are making a get
request to get all the data in here
which means that now if i
look here and just go to the end so
let's go to the very end i'm going to
put in 76
there is the new line that we have just
added
so i'm just going to zoom back in again
so you can see it a little bit better
so great this is all working fine i'm
really happy with how this is working of
course on here there are input tools to
download all the data you can also
filter and you can also reload manually
if you wish okay so these are all
options that you can do on the table as
well
great
um while we are here i'm just going to
change the color of this as i think blue
is a bit passive let's go ahead and make
it
red so just like that
wonderful and i'm just going to go back
to the first page so
page
one
great
so we can now add data
directly
to our database here
using the platform but there are other
things we could do as well so i can
actually also delete data from this
table so that it shows up here as well
so that is the next part we've just
added data next i'm going to show you
how to delete data 2.
okay
so for this part i'm actually going to
have to write a new query to delete data
however first off let's go ahead and add
a button to this table so i can do so
easily by selecting the table and this
time i'm not actually going to add
another column i'm going to add an
action so here are my actions and i'm
just going to call this
the delete action so here's my action i
just created and let's call this
delete
okay so just like so so there we go that
has now been appended to the left of my
table and on here i want to run a query
well that query is going to be the
delete row query so let's go ahead and
write it i'm just going to create a new
resource
and make sure that it is
using the northwind crm data and next i
want to not append data not update i
want to delete a single row from the
spreadsheet
so
that is looking good let's choose a
sheet well that is the northwind data
sheet and the sheet name that i want to
work with is the sales
order sheet so making sure that i'm on
this sheet right here
and now i'm just going to have to
filter to match row and let's go by
order id so i'm just going to select the
order id table making sure to spell it
exactly the same as we did
in here so i'm going to filter by order
id
and make sure that equals
the table so table
1 however it's spelt here and i'm just
going to put selected
row
data order
id so just like that so we're literally
going to search for a match by order id
and we're going to find that order id
and delete the entire row if it equals
the selected order id of this row okay
so i'm just gonna save this and let's
rename this to delete
selected
row
great and hit preview
so at the moment i'm on this row that's
the selected rom on and this is the row
that would get deleted from our
spreadsheet if i hit run okay so there
we go and of course this is great but we
don't want to run this manually we want
to attach it to the actions so i'm just
going to get that and run a query the
query i want to run is the delete
selected row and there we go so now
let's check it out
it's going to move that down here and
let's delete this row so i'm just going
to click here
and great so now if we look in here that
row is now deleted and of course we need
to refresh this data so on success of
this i want to add one more thing and i
want to trigger a query and that query
is to
get sales order data again and just
click save so let's go ahead and delete
another row so this time let's delete
this row and i'm just going to click
delete
so now that is deleted you'll just see
that disappear and ta-da this table
refreshes with the fresh data from this
spreadsheet
great so we are now adding data we are
deleting data this is looking awesome
now we have one last thing to do and
that is process a refund so for this i'm
going to show you how to do this using
the stripe api so to do this i'm
actually just going to create a
container so that we can store our
refund in here so that it looks a little
bit nicer visually so i've just gone
ahead and created that and now let's
also create another form that we're
going to put in here so i'm just going
to put in a form into here so let's
again just find a form that we can use
let's go ahead and put that in here like
so let's perhaps also change the button
color so i don't really like this button
let's change the color let's make it
some stripe colors
perhaps
so i'm just going to
use the hex curve that i have
here just like so and then i'm also
going to make this
button the full width and not only that
let's change what it says i'm going to
say refund and then also notify as we
want to send an email
notifying the person that the refund has
been made
so great let's go ahead and just put in
some text so we know what's happening in
here i'm just going to drag that in here
and this should say
create
refund
just like so
i don't need the
exclamation point now let's put in some
text
and then we'll just make a little note
so people need to select a row from the
sales
order
orders
to refund an amount okay because we want
to pick out all the information from a
row we select just like we did with the
delete in order to make our refund okay
so there we go the next thing i want to
populate so i want to now populate
fields by me just selecting a row so we
don't have to do much manually and this
is going to be the
charge id that we want to refund
so i'm just going to use
that we also want the
refund amount
so for this i'm actually going to use a
number input as this has to be a
number so i'm just going to drag that in
here like so
and put the label as
refund amount that we decide
and then let's also have a refund reason
for this i'm gonna actually have a
select because i only want there to be
three or so reasons that you can make a
refund and let's name this refund
reason
and let's populate the reasons so some
reasons could be
you know let's go ahead with
did not
we these are the values actually so
these are the values we're going to pick
them up by so didn't like i'm just going
to make them strings
this one is going to be too late
and this one is going to be
can itself so those are the values we
are going to use in order to pick out
our reasons but now let's have also a
way to read them a little bit better
so we have the values let's also perhaps
have some display values
so
i can actually just clear this
and
let's just test this out so test
test
so now there we go so it's either using
these or we can write our own and my own
are going to be
does
not like it
the second one is going to be
arrived
to
late
and the third one is going to be
would
like to
cancel
so just like so so great now we have our
select let's carry on the next thing i'm
going to do is just put in a text of the
refund summary so i'm just going to drag
in some text here
and this is just going to be a
refund
summary
okay so i'm just going to display a
little summary of what we are refunding
and why so i'm just going to drag that
in here some more text
oops
making sure that this
actually
it's a bit bigger
okay and in here i'm just gonna put the
refund amount so a little summary of
what we wrote above and i'm going to use
number input one
dot value to display that
okay so just like so that's my little
summary that i'm building refund amount
perhaps let's put some of these in here
so we've got the refund amount and then
let's also have reason
so again i'm just gonna put
reason and of course it's blank for now
because we haven't picked one this is
select one so i'm just gonna replace
this with select one but if i now choose
one like does not like it that will show
up here okay as the value so there we go
that is sort of a recap and of course if
i just put in
a number here that will show up there
too
and lastly i just want to be able to
send a message
along with you know the refund so what
we're what we're going to email to the
customer so once again i'm just going to
perhaps make this a little bit bigger
just like so and just stretch this out a
little bit
and this time i'm just going to use a
text input so text
input we could use the rich text editor
however i'm just going to use the text
area as i don't want anything crazy i
just want a message like
so they'll be sent over in an email but
of course if you'd like to use the rich
text editor too that is an option
okay great
now for the message itself well i want
to use values from here and what i can
do is make an email text so i can go
ahead and just write my own javascript
here so i'm going to use a javascript
transformer to do this
and i'm just going to use this to write
some javascript so for example if i get
the order id
so what is the order id well we know
that the order id is
whatever row we've selected from the
table so i'm going to use selected row
data order
id and save that as the order id the
other thing that i want to save is the
order amount so
let refund
amount
equal and this time i'm just going to
use the
number input one so number
input
one
value
just like so
and now we can construct our message
which is simply going to say dear order
and then the order number and then i
went ahead and made the refund of x
amount to your card if there's anything
else you can do please let me know okay
so that's all i'm going to write so
let's go ahead and do it
now let's also write different things
for different reasons that we chose for
the refund so in fact if i go let
opening
blurb
equal and then i'm just going to use a
switch case so i'm just going to make
that a little bit bigger for you i'm
going to switch out
the reason
so i'm gonna go
select
one
dot
value and switch it out
so
if the reason is
too
late
well then the opening
blurb
blurb
making sure to spell exactly as it's
written up there is going to be
i'm making sure it's back ticks actually
i'm so sorry
about your order
being
being late
i went
ahead and refunded
the
value
to your card and of course replacing
this with the refund amount so i'm
simply going to do
refunded
and then back tick plus
refunded amount
plus and then
the string again
okay so that's for the case too late
make sure this says select one okay
because we are using the value from
here select one so that is one
case essentially
okay so there we go and then let's put a
break
the next case that we're gonna cover is
the
didn't like so making sure i to spell it
exactly the same as we did here
so
didn't like did
not like
just like that didn't like and what
happens with this case
well let's again change the opening blub
so opening
blue
to be backtick
i'm
so
sorry
you did not like
your order so that's all i'm going to do
for this one making sure to put a full
stop at the end of these
and then finally the last case we're
going to do
is
cancel
and what happens when we cancel well the
opening blub this time
is going to be changed to making sure
that it's a capital b
i fully
canceled
your
order as you
requested full stop
great so that will change the opening
blurb now what do we want to return
well let's just return
order and then pass through
the order id
so essentially
this right here the order id
so let's get some curly braces
and in here i'm just going to put order
id
and then let's also
add a
another string
to this this time i'm going to put in
the
opening blurb
as it is after the changes with the
switch case
i went ahead
and refunded
and then we'll put in the
refund amount which we have also defined
at the top
refund amount
to your
card
and then let's finish it with best
wishes retal
bot
and save that
and let's rename this as email
text
just like so
email
so there we go email text
and in here well i'm just going to
replace the default value
with
email
text
dot
value
don't forget to put in the breaks
between each of the cases as well so
break and break also case should not
have
the double
dots here so just get rid of those and
there we go let's try change the reason
and great that is updating as it should
now i do want this to appear on separate
lines so i can simply do that like so so
in the string i'm just gonna
do a forward slash n
forward slash n
and preview that
save it
okay so that now spaces out let's do the
same after here so i'm just going to
copy this
put it after this string
and do so after here too
so
there we go
that is looking a lot neater and if we
of course change the reason again would
like to cancel that text should now
update too
and it's also updating with the refund
amount and the order id that we have
selected so this is looking great we've
got the text showing up this is looking
good i'm just going to make this a
little bit bigger still so that we can
read the whole text when it's longer
so just like that
wonderful
so this is looking good the next thing i
need to do is just connect this to the
stripe api to process the refund amount
on to the charge id
so if i just select this well the charge
id we need to actually show that in here
too so i'm just going to get another
text tag like so
and this is just going to display the
selected row so once again i'm going to
get the table 1
select a row data and i'm just going to
get the
charge id
so that should now show up for us on
whatever when we click the charge id is
the same as we are just using stripes
test api but just know that that will
change okay if it was different
okay so to recap we have just used a
transformer here i have used a
javascript transformer as because we
have three different messages we want to
send one for each drop-down value we
need to create a dynamic text field
value that will populate with the
correct message this is a perfect use
case for a transformer
so great we are collecting all the data
now to actually make a stripe refund so
for this i'm actually going to create a
new resource query and this time
well
i want to
create a new resource and this time i'm
going to select stripe so let's call
this crm stripe
resource you can call it whatever you
wish and we need to put an api key
so to do this all you have to do is sign
up to
stripe.com okay and here we are going to
all the documentations that we need in
order to create a refund so sign up to
stripe get your api key and then we are
essentially going to use this to create
a refund and we're also going to use
some test
charges okay so here is my stripe
dashboard i'm just going to sign in
just like so with my email address that
i used to sign up before and on your
dashboard you will see some test data
that you can use in order to test your
api
so
let's go to the dashboard
here is the home page and i can use the
test data okay in order to process a
refund just to see it's working here is
my key as well so i'm just going to copy
that and put it in here please do go
ahead and use your own as this will not
work i will be deleting this and just
create
resource just like so
so there we go i've now connected
my stripe api to my stripe dashboard
using my secret key now let's go ahead
and create a refund
so
what i want to do here
is
i essentially want to run a query when
manually triggered and i want to post
this to
refunds okay so it's a post request
there we go and in here
well the stripe account i'm gonna leave
that blank and leave this blank too the
amount where we know that this is going
to be the
number input one so number input one
dot value because that's the amount i
want to refund and the charge we also
know what the charge is i can actually
just take it from here so text 17 value
text 17
value you could have also taken it from
table data selected row charge id it's
up to you i just think this is perhaps a
little bit more foolproof as we're
actually seeing the charge id here
so great this is looking good let's save
that and then let's rename this to
post
refund
so just like so and just hit preview
and there we go you will see the
response of my refund you will see that
refund has been done we have refunded
the amount one okay and if you go to
your dashboard and just go to payments
so this is my test data you will see all
your refunds done here at the moment it
was just a preview okay so that is how
you would see it and to get your charge
id all you'd have to do is create a
payment and then let's say
we have a payment for 20
pounds
and then we'd have to just put input the
card information so if i google stripe
test cards
here we go
this is exactly what i need and i'm
going to make a fake payment so let's
just go ahead and use these test cards
i'm going to copy this and i'm going to
essentially make a fake payment using
this fake card data it says to use any
three digits so let's just go ahead and
do that as well as put any future date
so let's put 30th
or december three and then one two three
this is saying it's in the past so 12 21
there we go
so there we go and submit payment
okay so we've just created a fake
payment on our dashboard there we go
okay so here is our
payment and if i want to get the charge
id as we need to get the charge id in
order to make a refund here is the
charge id
so instead of just taking
the charge id that i have hard-coded
here please go ahead and essentially
replace this with your own charge ids
here
so just like so
and just literally just
replace it with all the charge ids i
have here
all the way to the bottom so that you
can put your own charge id in order to
make refunds
so there we go i've just replaced all
the charge ids with my own charge id
from the stripe api dashboard click save
refresh this page so we get the new
charge ids showing up
okay
so there we go that is now updated with
the charge id that we just put in here
and now if i make a refund so instead of
testing this out i'm actually gonna run
this
so at the moment i'm refunding the
amount of zero let's go ahead and make
the refund amount one
and click run
there we go we have now refunded one to
the 20
pound charge that we have here and if we
look at this so let's go ahead and look
at all the payments again
you will see a partial refund of one was
made onto this payment so we have just
partially refunded this charge right
here
so hopefully that makes sense please
watch this a few times if it does not
make sure to replace all this data here
with your own charge that you created on
the stripe dashboard
okay
great
so we are processing refunds from this
dashboard now
let's carry on
the next thing that i want to do is
actually
notify us when we create the refund so
the refund's just been made but i also
want to send an email so i'm going to do
that next for this we are going to
integrate with google mail so hopefully
you do have google mail if you don't you
can use the sendgrid api too however
this is just my personal preference but
it is up to you whichever one you choose
so to do this i'm actually going to
create a new query again
so just here and this time i'm going to
create a new resource and choose
okay so that is the one i want to use
let's go ahead and call this gmail like
so the host the host is going to be
smtp.gmail.com
just like so as we are using gmail the
port is going to be 465. the username
you just have to literally use your own
uh email address for this so i'm going
to put any free
codecamp.org and the password it's
actually the password for your email
address so i'm going to go ahead and do
that
and put in my actual password in here
and just test the connection
okay so my connection was a success so
i'm going to create this resource
however if you are having issues you
might need to do some extra
configuration on your gmail so you might
have to go into your actual gmail
account so i'm going to show you how to
do this this is something that i had to
do in order to get this working and in
your settings
with forwarding and pop
imap
just make sure that you enabled imap and
make sure you've enabled pop as well and
one last thing you need to do is enable
all apps like so okay so you're sort of
lowering i guess your security settings
and allowing third parties to use your
email on your behalf
okay great
so that is something that you need to do
in order to get this
done hopefully that works after you've
enabled those three things and now we
can get to hooking this up so that it
sends an email when we press the button
so let's continue with this our query
well let's use the gmail query just made
the from email we're gonna do anya
at free
codecamp.org
the two email i'm just gonna hard code
this for now to kubo anya
gmail.com
and then the subject is gonna be your
refund
has gone through
and then i'm just gonna get the whole
text area one so text
area
one
dot
value okay and let's save this
and now let's run it
and if i look in my email you will see i
got an email saying my refund has gone
through
okay from anya at freecoecamp.com
so this is looking good i'm really happy
with how this is looking so far
let's
carry on of course we can also have an
input for the email that is completely
up to you in fact i would recommend it
so just go ahead and just drag an input
tag so for example once again i would do
so like
this let's just go ahead and put you
know email address that we want to send
this to
just drag it out like so
and let's put the label as email
address
and this just means that i'm going to
get text input 12 this time
text
input
12
dot value
okay so whatever email we put in here
that's the email that it will be sent to
great
so we're sending an email we're making a
refund let's just hook up this button
because we want
this to trigger the query for yes indeed
gmail but also posting a refund first
and let's just make sure that this is
renamed to send
email
just for readability
so we are triggering that but we're also
going to trigger the send email query 2.
so two things are being triggered
so this is looking great i'm really
happy with this i'm going to do one last
thing before moving on to use the
postgres approach and that is just show
you how to use mapping in order to use
the two databases so for example if i
want to use the employee id to show me
the employee name
okay so i'm gonna get the three i'm
gonna look in here and i'm gonna get the
name i'm gonna show you how to do this
now
so let's go ahead and just create an
overview of an order so i'm gonna drag
this in here like so
and let's call this
overview of order
number
and i'm just going to put in the order
number
so it's going to be the selected row
this time so i'm just going to go into
table 1
selected row
data
order
i d
making sure number is
here just get rid of that so we're going
to show the order number
and once again i'm just going to drag
through some explainer text explain to
the user what's happening here
select
row
from
sales
okay so that's sort of explaining what's
happening and now once again i'm
actually going to get some text here
and this is going to have the customer
name
let's also do it for the
shipping
address
let's also have the
employee
name
and then one last thing i'm going to do
is just use this little cool thing
so
if i just go down here there's so many
things you can use of course i'm going
to use a timeline so i'm going to use a
timeline to display essentially the
order details and how far it's gone and
so on so i'm just going to drag that in
here like so
and
great
so these can be a little bit smaller in
fact i am going to shrink them down a
little bit
there we go
and now
i'm going to use the text
component again and just put it in here
because what i want to do is essentially
look in the table
and instead of having the customer as an
id i want to show the name by looking in
here finding the customer id and
returning back the name okay so i can do
so easily all i'm going to do is just
delete all of this
and this time i am going to get
table
customer table so this is table
2.
so let's get table
two let's get the data from it
and i'm gonna pass through
the table ones
selected
row
data
cust id
okay so i'm just passing that through i
need to make sure that this is an
integer so i'm going to wrap it and pass
inch
to make sure it is
and i'm actually just going to minus one
from it so that's what i'm passing
through i'm passing through the index
and i'm getting back the
contact
name
okay because i'm going in here i'm
looking in here i'm passing through the
index and i'm returning the contact name
and the index is whatever
this
number is minus one okay
so that is how you would do that that is
how you would essentially join data from
two different tables let's do the same
for the employee name this time
so just down here
it's essentially all these same thing
however this time i'm going to look in
table
three
i believe it's table three let's have a
look is this table
this is table five i can use table five
or i can use
table four it's completely up to me
let's go ahead and use table four why
not
so let's look in table four and this
time let's get back the
first name because contact name doesn't
exist so first name
and i'm going to also get the
making sure this is not a custom id but
this time we're going to pass through
the employer id so we're getting the
first name i'm going to copy all this
because i also want to get the
second name
so there we go
first name and
last name
so
this is looking good making sure that
that's a space
and
wonderful
so that again is how you would get data
from two different tables and the last
thing i'm going to do is just show the
shipping address this is actually really
easy because all i'm going to do is go
look in table one
which is the main table get selected row
data
ship
address okay because i'm looking table
one which is this table and just getting
the ship address
so here's a nice little overview for us
and of course the orders well this is
again easy because i am simply going to
get rid of
these
i'm going to use the curly braces to go
into table one so the main table
selected
row
data
order
date
so we've got the order date
the next thing we need to do is
i'm going to change this to be
order created as well
order created and then let's have
order required by
and then the final one will be order
shipped or shipped date it's up to you
so
shift data just so people can see the
status of an order so this required y so
that should be required
date
and this should be shipped date
great so now whatever order we select
this will all update okay so as you will
see here that's been updated let's click
this one as you will see here this is
customer id 34 and this is employee 4
but if we click it we will see that
customer id 34 is shy cohen and the
employee is yale palette let's go ahead
and click another one let's do this one
yatsec jalito and sven buck is the
employee
okay and of course these are updating
too
so wonderful this is looking so so good
just a few final pieces of styling and
then we are ready to move on so
first off perhaps let's make this a tiny
bit bigger so i'm just going to use some
markup to do this and put three hashes
here
like so and that will immediately turn a
lot bigger like that and then perhaps
let's also have another one here
and i'm not sure what we should call
this perhaps it's called this
let's just call it overview
because that is essentially what this is
over
here
make sure to spell it correctly
and then here let's also have let's
perhaps take out sales orders in here
because i think it's a little bit
obvious
uh i'm going to move this up a little
bit so move up the button
let's move this down
a few
smidges
let's also put this in line with the
other thing
and this let's call this
sales
order
man
okay so i think that's looking a lot
more obvious as to what that is and then
let's also make a little
header so here we go i'm just gonna
select the header and make the
background color let's make it this blue
just to keep everything sort of the same
color and now let's also put in some
text so i'm just going to drag this over
into here and once again let's just use
with markup
sergeant
pep
purse store
just like so and then perhaps i supposed
to put e
commerce
crm okay so just making it super clear
what this is
you can of course
e-commerce crm you can do so much
styling in here it's
honestly completely up to you
uh i am just gonna do the bare minimum
but there is literally hours and hours
of styling that you can do to this
perhaps let's actually make this one
line i don't think it should be two
so there we go
just like so and we can also add a
profile so depending on who's logged in
they will have a different profile here
so i'm gonna go ahead and choose an
avatar
and just drag that in so there i am
okay so and that will be for whoever the
user is we can also have
various other things so if you do choose
to build this out even further we can
also have a burger
menu meaning that if you want to add
different pages or if you know you want
to start moving things out for example
if you want the refund page to be on its
own page you can also have a navigation
bar here which will show you different
menu items and that will take you to
another page so again like you could
have the refund page on its separate
page if you want that is an option for
you
too
so there we go i hope you've enjoyed
this everything is now connected
everything is working we can issue
refunds we can send emails we can add
new data to this table if it doesn't
exist already on our spreadsheet for
example perhaps you want to put any
manual order that wasn't taken online
you can sift through customers using the
filter tools you can look through all
your orders you can look at team members
you can look at demographics you can
have an overview of how many orders are
shipped how many orders you sold at full
price literally pretty much anything you
could want
okay
so this is done for part one hopefully
you've enjoyed this section if you want
to learn how to
use postgres with this database that is
coming up next
okay now it's part two in which we
switch out our database to be a postgres
database okay so to do this i'm actually
just going to imitate a postgres
database by
putting in some data
in here using the manage database
approach
so all i'm going to do is simply get all
of this data that we see right here
so as you can see i've already copied it
it is under database samples
postgresql northwind dot sql make sure
you are in the postgres sql section and
just copy all of this
or if you want you can literally just
get the file as i have here and then in
this file before we get to switching
this out so as you can see here we are
creating a database we are then creating
tables so category region territory and
of course sales order so these are all
the tables that we see here
we are essentially creating the tables
here and then importing the data
but as you know we also need to create
another column and that is with the
charge id this is your charge id this is
the charge id that you should get from
your stripe dashboard as you should
remember
from before so if you go back to your
stripe dashboard
under payments this is the 20 pound
payment that we made by creating payment
here in the test data section and all
you need to do is get the charge id so
you will see the charge id here it
starts with ch so get that and we are
going to create another column in our
table and input the charge id
so we're going to do so in here let's
search for the sales order table
so here we are creating the table and
just after ship country i'm just gonna
add
charge id
okay
and then in here well
sure let's just make it the same as the
customer id so just put in that
like
so
great so we've done that and now let's
actually go to inputting the data so
here you will see we are inserting the
data we of course need to add another
field in here so what i'm actually going
to do is just find anything that looks
like this
and then replace it with
ship country but then also add charge id
okay so let's go ahead and replace all
of those
so that is now added i don't think we
use ship country anywhere else apart
from in this sales order which is why i
thought it was safe to do this
we indeed don't it seems to be only in
this section and of course we also need
to input the charge id
so this is going to take a little bit
longer because we can't use the same
approach there's different data being
added into here or times so i
essentially need to make a comma and
then just paste
the charge id so let's get this charge
id
into here like so
so they're really like i said isn't an
easy way to do this let's copy this
because i'm just gonna
maybe if we select everything in here
that is a parenthesis with a semicolon
then we can essentially input
the
charge id before this i'm just going to
copy all of these this will take a while
so just bear with me this is not an easy
process but we have to do it in order to
get our data to look exactly the same as
it does on the google spreadsheet
so this is great of course all this data
that was given to us it's important to
learn how to start working with huge
data states like this especially when
you go on to becoming a software
developer because this is likely the
amount of data that you will work with
in a small startup for example or a
bigger startup whatever you are
thinking to join okay so we are nearly
that at the bottom of the sales orders
that we are inserting
and now all i'm gonna do is just delete
make a comma
and then i am going to paste
i don't need to do that i'm just going
to paste
the
charge as a string like so
and then i'm also going to
just shut that off
like
this so i think this is looking okay
hold on we seem to have
messed something up here
so we've got the postal
code
we then have the ship country and then
we have the charge
id
great
so i am happy with this
let's save this and now i'm literally
going to get all of this data again so
copy all of it
everything that we have just altered so
once again we have added another column
to the sales order table and we have
just inserted the charge ids into the
table too
so now i yes i am just going to copy all
of this
and then go up here
and let's create a new query so resource
query and this time i'm going to choose
to use the managed database so we can
essentially just insert it all into here
so i'm just going to paste everything
that we copied this might slow down your
computer so just let it do its thing
because we are going to insert data into
the manage database okay so just go
ahead and click save
and just wait for that to do its thing
okay and once that is done let's go
ahead and rename this i'm going to
rename this to add data
this seems to be an error so let's just
go ahead and
delete the first lines
okay so just delete this line
and just click save
ah we made the
character type too long so where we
create the sales order
let's just find that again we're going
to increase this
varchar
we can make it 40 just to make sure that
we are
giving it enough space
and click save
great so that is how we add data to our
managed database now let's use it
because at the moment we essentially
have all this data but that includes all
the tables so these right here i just
want to get one table and that's the
sales orders in order to say that we can
replace it
so we can use the postgres database on
the main table right here so let's go
ahead and create a new resource here
so resource query
and make sure that is on the manage
database and i'm just going to select
all because that's how you'd get all
from
sales
order okay so just like we wrote it in
here sales order it has to be exactly
the same as sales order written here
and then let's click preview
and there we go
we are getting the table along with the
charge id that we have just added let's
go ahead and rename this to something so
i'm going to save this and let's save
this get
sales
order
data postgres sql so that we know that
it's different to the other get data
query so there we go that's what i've
saved as and now i can simply get this
table
and replace this
with this query okay so now we are using
the postgres data instead of the
spreadsheet data
so that was super easy
there we go let's carry on
so now let's get the customer data so
again i'm just going to make a new query
and this time let's call this
get
customer
data
postgres sql
and again we're just going to do select
all
from
and this time we're going to go from the
customer table
so just like so save and run
and this time i'm just going to replace
the customers so i'm going to go in here
select this table
get customer data
pg
sql
making sure that it's felt exactly the
same
so let's just go ahead and do this for
the other tables some of this will be
broken because of course we are not
using this anymore but we will fix that
in a bit let's just make sure we do all
of these first next we need to get the
order details so again new
resource query let's call this get
order
details
p g
sql
and this time i'm going to do
select
all from
order
detail
okay and save and run
so
this is all looking good let's go ahead
and replace
this with get order detail
p g
p g sql
same for
in here get sales order data
p g sql
however this time we need to go into the
data
and we actually need to get into the
shift
date okay and then filter by order or
you can filter by ship date you can of
course rename this to whatever you wish
so perhaps it should do shipped date
so for each item that exists let's call
it a ship date
okay so there we go and then i'm just
gonna get the
sales order data
data
this time i'm gonna go by order id
length this is just because our tables
are a bit different now if we go into
here i will show you this so all i would
do is simply go into here and find the
query that i am making so for example
get sales order data once again here's
our data but it's now an object not an
array i would then have to go into the
shipped address which is an array and
then filter out the
shipped
date
okay
so that is the shipped address where's
the ship date ship date and i'll just
filter out by these so it's just a
little bit of a different structure that
you have to be aware of but you can also
have a look in here if you ever get
stuck
so great and this time again we are not
filtering out by
if it doesn't have
an empty string we're just gonna go by
no
okay wonderful
and same for this one here
so this progress circle
we're gonna get the order details
postgres sql
data we want to go into the
discount this time
and then we're going to filter by the
discount itself so discount
discount
and if it does not equal 0.00
actually we should do then we're going
to get the data order id length
so there we go
order id
and there we go so that is now back to
normal this is all looking good
these should be okay because we are
working
by table on some of these so that's fine
however this one again this should be
updated
so get customer order data postgres sql
data and this time we need to get by the
customer id
because that is what we want we all know
exactly how many customers and once
again for this so get sales order data
post address sql data and let's again do
it by order id
okay wonderful
so i think this should be nearly it just
a few more to go let's go ahead and
update these right here so again get
sales order data
postgres sql
and this time i can actually just select
the customer id here and hide the order
making sure this is also by employee id
so that is now back to normal and this
one well we need to get the employee
data so let's go ahead and do that let's
make a new query
and let's call this get employee
data
postgres sql again
and this time we're going to do select
all from
employee
e
just like so and save and run
and then once again it's just a case of
replacing this
so
get employee data
p g sql
great and the same for here
so i'm just going to add
p g sql
and same for the
demographic so customer data pg sql
for this one however we also need to do
some additional things
so let's go ahead and just make sure
that this is by country
so there we go country and customer id
so wonderful and like i said these are
the last things we need to do
so in this one well essentially we just
need to get the we don't need to get the
contact name anymore
so we just need to do that
because we are filtering by contact name
instead
so there we go and just do the same for
here so again we are going to the data
and then we are going into the first
name array and just getting the value
so we do need to go into any objects and
the same for here
last name
and then we can get rid of
this like so
okay we have one last thing to do in
fact two more things because we also
need to
delete
data
so i'm going to show you how to do that
again we're going to make a new query
and this time i'm going to delete a
sales row again i'm just going to add pg
sql so it's clear how we're going to do
this so this is not to get this is
delete i'm going to do a delete a sales
row and this time i'm going to write
delete
from
sales order table so let's get the sales
order table
where
order id
equals and then i'm going to get the
main table so table one selected row
data
order id
so this is how you would essentially
delete
a row a complete row
okay so i'm going to save that and i'm
going to get this query because we're
going to have to replace it in the
actions
so where we have actions here
don't forget that we do need to change
this so let's trigger a different query
now and it's going to be delete sales
row so that is updated and one last
thing we need to do is the add
row
well we seem to have done something
wrong in here
oh no that's the other one so delete
sales row is now
added to here
to the action let's just double check it
is the correct one
so delete and yes delete sales row is
the one that's going to run
and then also
let's make sure to write
a query to add
data so once again a resource query and
let's call this add
sales
row
postgres sql
and now to add a sales row well
essentially we are going to have to so i
already have pre-written this for us so
i'm just going to show you this
this is how we would do this so here we
go we are essentially just copying how
we did it when we inserted sales rows
into here
so sales order
so we have simply copied this and
instead of inputting the hard-coded data
we are using data from our
model so let's just double check this is
all right as something seems to not be
liking this the order id well that is
text input one value so let's change
that
the customer id that is going to be text
input two so let's change that text
input 2
just like so the employee id is going to
be text input 3
text input
3
the
order date is date time two
so let's change that
which makes this date time one
for the required date the ship date well
that is just date
from what i remember date
1
and then the shipper id
perhaps let's make this a little bit
smaller shipper id is text input 11. so
let's change
that the fright is text input 9
the ship name is text input 10
and then the last ones
is ship address so once again i'm just
going to make the smallest we can all
see it
ship address is text input 2.
ship city
text input
six
ship region is text input
eight
postal code is a four
and then we just have ship country
which is a five
and of course the
charge id which we're gonna hard code as
this
that's right so let's just go ahead and
delete all this
i'm just gonna put an empty string like
so
and save that
okay so there's our ad sales row which
means now
let's make sure that on this submit we
make the right query
so submit i want to run the query
add sales order
pg sql instead
and
great
so let's run that
and
wonderful
so cool
this is looking good i believe that's it
i believe we have now replaced
everything that we need i hope you've
enjoyed this tutorial please do let me
know if there's anything that you would
want me to add to this i would be more
than happy to do that uh hopefully
you've learned a lot in this and you can
really take this and make things your
own one last thing that we can do is of
course filter as well so i'm actually
going to show you how to do that super
quick
so this time i'm actually just going to
make a text input and this is how we're
going to query data from the sales order
so for example if we have this here and
we can search
i'm just going to write a super simple
query for this so
let's go ahead and do that now
so i'm just going to click here
resource query
let's call this
search
sales
orders
p g sql
and in here i'm going to select all
from sales
order
where
i'm going to get the
text input 13 so text input
13 dot value
or
order id equals
and then i'm going to get
just put pass int and pass through the
text
input
13
so text
input
13
dot value so this should be where it
doesn't so just put a bang there
okay
so now i should be able to filter let's
just save this and that should just run
every time we change the value in here
so if i just want to search by order i
can do so like that
and then all just show me the search for
data in here now to update this in here
well we're gonna have to change this up
so let's just switch this out to
searched
search sales orders instead so get sales
orders
search
sales orders
just like that okay so now it's hooked
up and i can make
the table listen out to
search for any order that i want
wonderful
so hopefully that makes sense
i hope you've enjoyed this tutorial
again if there's anything i've missed
please do let me know this has been a
long one but i hope you've learned a lot
and i can't wait to see you in some
future tutorials too
thanks so much again and i'll see you
soon